welcome back okay we're talking about
dynamic mode decomposition which is a
powerful data-driven method to extract
spatial temporal coherent structures
from high dimensional data and give you
a linear model for how those evolve in
time okay we recently wrote a book on
this dynamic mode decomposition it's we
have a website DMD book calm and so what
I'm gonna do today is I'm gonna download
the code and data and I'm gonna walk you
through how easy it is to actually get
started with DMD okay so go to DMD book
comm download the code and the data and
unzip them into the same folder okay so
now here we are in my downloads I have
this data folder and in data there is
another data folder and all of these
code like every chapter of the book the
code for that chapter is in one of these
folders so I'm going to go into my
fluids chapter and now you can see all
of these codes to compute DMD on a fluid
so I'm actually going to compute DMD on
that flow past a cylinder data the fluid
flow past a cylinder so I have all of
these codes some of them load the data
some of them plot the data some compute
the singular value decomposition or the
P OD and I'm gonna start this one which
is compute DMD so you can fire this up
on your own I've already loaded my data
so I hope you can read this it's a
cylinder all dot map so that's all of
the data for the flow past a cylinder
and it's such that's essentially full
vorticity fields and each column is a
vorticity field in time so as the
columns of all time is evolving so the
first thing I do is I take my big data
and I stack it into my X and X prime
matrices okay so the first M minus 1
columns go into X the second to n
columns go into X prime okay so that's
the first step I take my data and I
stack it into X and X prime then what I
do is I compute a singular value
decomposition of X to find the dominant
coherent structures my p OD mode my
proper orthogonal decomposition modes of
my data matrix X and notice I'm using an
economy SVD or else this would be super
expensive
okay so you has my dominant coherent
structures okay now if I do that I could
probably plot semi-log why the diagonal
elements of s this is always a good idea
is to actually plot what your singular
values look like maybe I'll plot it a
little bit thicker line with two and so
what you can see this is on a log scale
these are my singular values evolving in
sorry my singular values this is the
first singular value second third fourth
fifth sixth seventh and so on and so
forth so this is index and this is the
log of the singular value in the Sigma
matrix you can see that there's a
dominant singular value here that
essentially corresponds to the mean flow
because I didn't subtract out the mean
flow and then after that first singular
value they essentially come in these
mode pairs because the so if you if you
are familiar with this fluid flow past a
cylinder you know that there are is this
kind of periodic vortex shedding motion
that's given by these higher harmonic
sine and cosine mode pairs okay so
that's what these look like in the
singular value decomposition what I can
do based on the singular value
decomposition is I can pick where to
truncate how many of these modes to keep
and how many to throw away so in this
case I think I'm choosing to keep 21
modes and I'm going to throw away the
rest so here I set the desired rank of
my d-md approximation to be 21 this is
one of the knobs you get to tune in DMD
is you get to pick how many modes you
have how many DMD modes how many PID
modes you're basing this off of so I'm
gonna try twenty-one modes so it's
basically that dominant mean flow and
then ten harmonic pairs of eigen values
and now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
pull out the first 21 columns of U the
first 21 by 21 sub block of Sigma and
the first 21 columns of V so that's what
I'm doing here I'm pulling out the first
art columns of U the first R by R block
of Sigma and the first R columns of V
and then all I do so the DMD procedure
is very simple after that I build my
little reduced a tilde and
it's the best fit linear model that
tells me how these 21 PID modes are
evolving in time okay so this 21 by 21
linear model tells me how these these
mode coefficients evolve in time and
it's easy to compute here so this is
just based on the data I have I
pseudo-inverse to compute the big a and
I project it onto these 21 modes to get
a 21 by 21 matrix then I compute the
eigen decomposition of a tilde so I get
the eigenvectors and eigenvalues and
then the last the final step is
reconstructing from these small twenty
one-dimensional eigenvectors
reconstructing my big high dimensional
full state DMD eigenvectors in phi so
you can see that the actual DMD
procedure is just a few lines of code
I'm gonna run this okay and now I
actually have all of those all of those
structures now all I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna plot the actual DMD modes the
first I guess I'm gonna plot these DMD
modes using this plot cylinder command
which you can download and read about
okay so let's try that and it's going to
run this pretty fast I think okay so it
ran all of them and these are
essentially the different DMD mode pairs
okay so that's a DMD mode pair that
oscillates at a coherent frequency
here's another one down here and you can
see that they're getting broader and
broader that's a mode pair here's
another one I'm basically just plotting
all of the DMD pairs that I've that I've
cooked up okay so these are the actual
DMD modes that came out of that analysis
okay in this case they happen to look a
lot like p OD modes because the system
is is a very normal system okay and
that's that's a detail that we'll talk
about later but but what I really want
to get out here is you can first of all
download all the code and data so you
have this it's on that website just
download it running the DMD only takes a
few lines of code so we you know it's
just these lines right here we did a
singular value decomposition we pull out
the dominant coherent structures and
then we do the best-fit regression and
tilda we did the eigen decomposition and
we reconstruct the modes kind of these
three lines here and then it's easy to
reshape these columns these modes back
into flow fields and see what the
coherent structures are that are
oscillating at a fixed frequency in time
so the last thing that I want to do is
sometimes I want to plot the DMD
spectrum so here I'm going to basically
plot a unit circle because this is a
discrete time model and then I'm going
to plot the real and diagonal parts of
those d-md eigenvalues sorry the real
and the imaginary parts of those DMD
eigenvalues and this is what it looks
like here so not only did I get those
coherent structures those dominant DMD
modes but I also figure out what are the
eigenvalues what are the time dynamics
corresponding to each of those modes and
since this is coming in complex
conjugate pairs that explains why I had
those kind of complex cosine and sine
spatial mode pairs that are going to be
they're going to be oscillating out of
phase with each other okay so you can do
this yourself you can download this code
in fact in the DMD book code there's
actually a DMD function so you don't
even have to write any of this you can
just plug your data X into the DMD
function choose the order R and it'll do
all of this for you but I encourage you
try to take your data and actually plug
in your data into this and start doing
the DMD and plotting the eigenvalues
look at the singular values you know
things like that okay thank you